sors-le bébé réveille-toi Oh papa s'il
te plait ok
la ville la plus excitante du monde
ici l'eau
pourquoi as-tu demandé un interprète pour que nous
puissions parler d'amour
Neji chronomètre wakanda Kiko précision
continue
tu ne me possèdes pas Je ne t'ai jamais possédé mais  Je
t'aime
je veux utiliser le téléphone pendant deux minutes
yamaneika donc déluge Valeo c'est un jus et
ceux qui n'achètent pas la bouffe les autres
soirs
je mets proportion sur la photo mais c'est
pas pareil je pense peut être que tu devrais
me pardonner
Oh  Dorothy j'aime
- - Selah tu peux faire tout ce que tu veux
certains disent que c'est magique
nous allons t'offrir de la musique d'amour de
peut-être que tu nous trouveras
oui sorcier je peux tu dois emprunter une
pierre à la fête
toi